[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il a revu arrête moi si tu peux
vous êtes très bon sur ce qui se passe
ou ça vous êtes ma came emplois non
c'est pareil cette veste est très belle
ah ouais mais très vite j'ai
l'impression qu'on sait quoi oui dites
moi peut-être que on va faire un petit
bout de chemin ensemble ah bon
c'est quoi ces petits bouts de petits
bouts par les badauds qui bout on n'est
pas d'accord ben oui savez-vous alors
battu mal écouté
semaine dernière oui on ne l'a pas
souhaité alors mais parce que j'étais
pas invité et je peux être cadeaux alors
je tiens vous avez terminé avant
l'anniversaire mais cyril valery douleur
je tente encore une fois ça va partir de
là non mais ça ne m'intéresse à partir
du nantais pas à la 37e sur la tête de
l'âge mais quand l'idée est bien sûr la
tête de la mienne que je vous inviter au
monde où j'ai prévenu aux équipes que je
sais que ça vous gonfle les
anniversaires donc j'ai prévenu d'alger
prime le dictateur est ce que vous avez
vu quelqu'un qui vous invite qui dit à
une personne tandis traces cyril à mon
avenir ça m'a pas dit à moi qui m'a vu
naître son anniversaire il vous a oublié
mais bon comme vous pourrez vous blesser
ou la descente et j'appelle castaldi
donné samedi j'ai dit qu'est ce que tu
fais mais l'image fait la nique à cette
chasse à bulles est pas là jusqu'à
l'anniversaire de sa fille sasha sacha
sacha qui base sa cheikh bass mon sachet
le ba ba willie versa il m'a pas invité
si mais vous étiez la tête d'affiche de
mon anniversaire n'est pas venu non non
non il va pas vite et nous non plus
directement ce que tu m'a invité
directement mépris mais parce que je
sais que vous avez un emploi du temps
vous avez votre l'état terres deviennent
comme en asie peur que frais pour les ma
foi un petit peu j'avoue parce que je
sais que regardez regardez regardez moi
vous y avait des tas d'amis alors non je
suis pas allé non mais attendez
mezzanine normes et mythomane nuit bah
oui
thomas il va planter des amis non non
non parce qu'il est venu à la maison
après castaldi ouais ça me fait du bien
dont il m'a dit si tu allais me retire
de sa chaleur
[Applaudissements]
les médecins
avaient en fait j'en fait vous mélangez
tout c'est pas grave c'est l'âge
avec castaldi et on a choqué des trucs
dont je vous ai eu ma demi finale et je
devais aller le naturaliste j'y suis
allé non mais pas du est un menteur tu
m'as dit je peux les bons génies à cyril
je suis à l'aise et universal base que
je pensais pas finir après qu'il a dit
oui mais castaldi est arrivée des deux
avait un cerveau plus petit que les yeux
c'est pourquoi sans déconner tu as menti
notamment 10 alouettes non mais je vous
jure qui il me l'a dit ça vous dire que
des menteurs ben ouais et des frais
lotois de vous le promets ribes l'année
quoi effet l'on entre nbc des salopards
pourquoi ces trois éthique parce que
vous lui montrez tout le temps allez
vas-y fais ta chronique si je te dis
j'en ai gros sur la patate moi j'en ai
gros sur la patate parce que ni
souhaitée ni de cadeau là ça commence à
bien faire
c'est comme chaque semaine on commençait
bien avec par toutes les petites
saucisses des chroniqueurs il ya eu de
la triche est un mélange édition se fini
les soucis j'ai vu des jeunes j'ai envie
de prendre congé pour une trousse bureau
mathieu taille-crayon canaux de
chroniqueurs et eu de la triche cette
semaine dans l'émission alors s'offrir
la qui trichent avec classe mais il y en
a qui trichent avec un dignité on
s'accorde ce goal inside une affaire
qu'il a coûté très cher time à john
bâtés
ça quand on le zeit pp salut à tous et
bienvenue dans cette côte second
l'inside de pmp et on commence tout de
suite avec le pourri l'escroc le
tricheur de la semaine et au plus il
aucun style ce bâtard si guillaume
genton
[Applaudissements]
et on continue avec un tricheur de jenny
and intelligent un visionnaire bah si
les goûts
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
et
attention cette semaine clash peu ce
tweet sur le plat tout pompé financier
bnp reçoit benjamin
mais en effet j'aimerais donner sa
chance à quelqu'un qui débute à benjamin
il fallait pas tacler benji mathieu
s'amuse anton kohler chacun un cadeau
individuelle est ce que ces chaînes sont
devant vous merci guillaume c'est à
l'effigié de matthieu delormeau c'est un
gros
[Rires]
quel est l'animateur qui s'est passé du
corps mal au moins de 10 secondes c'est
sûr et je rappelle que le taux
d'efficacité dans la bonne période ce
que tu as un panaris
nom
et scoop cette semaine on a appris qu
isabelle morini bosc était une grosse
crainte tôt c'est une marche mais ça va
le faire mais après je roule pour le
deuxième set ça prend quatre minutes
montre en main
propre tout ça
il est un peu la montée l'arrêt de
travail sur animaux tv c'est l'autre
monte à la tête hulu c'est une femme
extrêmement brillante très agréable de
compagnie c'est pas la balle au
[Rires]
bond la rythmique au cshl base qui vous
parle dit moi avec des oufs sur ce
plateau sur la terrasse pas possible
vous avez pris quoi
mais dis-moi frère tu as déjà vu ça sur
une autre chaîne sur la vie de ma mère
ils prennent les clés ferme le rideau
merci bonsoir
fou
faux faux la chine aujourd'hui fait face
à des problèmes économiques très
importants
il ya des problèmes de chômage très
important et compris chez les jeunes
diplômés soit
[Applaudissements]
sa race cyril cette semaine sans le
savoir vous avez faire une prière aux
toilettes accord
[Rires]
title situerait alors rattrapée vous
rattrapez vous de l'anniversaire et bien
manger à la maison ce soir aux enchères
bat allez vas-y
alors moi je ne mélange pas le personnel
et professionnel ah bon oui casas bahia
venaient manger avec genton
exsangue et jeunes au hockey
mais l'assiette à ma mère elle est très
mignonne ouais mais comme beaucoup la
mère de
rythme mais sans le savoir si vous avez
mené l'une des interviews les plus
incroyables de l'histoire de la
télévision française cette semaine une
interview
comment dire qu'il va marquer l'histoire
du paf une interview dans laquelle vos
origines maghrébo tunisiennes sont
ressortis c'est quoi eh bien regardez
franchement c'est l'ambassadeur regardez
c'est exprès
la chance d'avoir toutes les infos sur
l'état de santé de charlène on est tous
très inquiets lara sera on est obligé de
parler au conditionnel à ce que personne
n'est vraiment un monaco c'est très
particulier à doha à la halle à doha la
gauche ya un problème concernant hommes
concernant charlene ait là quoi bertrand
la pauvre mishkin al-sada elle était
nageuse a été trop qu'ils ont uni qui
sont visées et elle ne supportait pas
porter ses lunettes lors des réceptions
officielles
mais qu'est ce qu'elle a eu ce qu'ils
nient ce qui nous a surtout à
l'extérieur
je crois qu'elle alla feu dans la la
fenêtre je te jure alors et donc il ya
quelques mois elle est apparue les
cheveux rasés et non jours sur la toile
ah oui elle avait les cheveux gras des
fonds madoff thomas 9 absolument pas
tant québécois avec un oui apple à
britney est là mais elle
est totale c'est vrai qu'il ya t-il ou
princier n'est sûr à la totale charlene
de monaco dont il sera absent lors de la
fête nationale ça veut dire que son état
initial
n'en savez
quoi
il est difficile d'avoir des
informations lé relais toulalan elle est
grave sont des questions il est très
présente
trois fois rien laura jeune homme c'est
à dire qu'elle n'est pas bien
[Rires]
[Musique]
s'éloigner de la principauté romane non
puisque je veux dire qu'elle était à
l'hôpital princesse grâce
mais oui la journée très vite ça va
d'accord a dit tu as écris moi je
comprends rien de ce que vous rappelle
rien
[Applaudissements]
le dr c'est le meilleur
olala
serré il avant de repartir j'ai décidé
de lancer nouvelle séquence à ça
s'appelle le on l'a vu vos chroniqueurs
estiment ne pas être assez payé donc du
coup figurez-vous qu'il essaie
d'arrondir leurs fins de mois en faisant
des petits ménages non et oui et vous
savez je suis leur dis que je sais
toujours à toulouse dans ce taux est bas
c'est parti c'est la nouvelle séquence
que j'appelle le on l'a vu
[Musique]
et vous savez qu'on a vu on a vu
matthieu delormeau au casting de dirty
dancing et bouge bien son petit cul
celui-ci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est en train de motiver une réunion à
l'elysée on a vu bernard montiel faire
un petit tour sur un bateau très très
connu que
voulez-vous aller dans une vraie fête
essayez de faire des petits sa vie c'est
mieux au sport capuche est là chaque de
sport capuche eniko gyori
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
gilbert des sa brouille avec bruce lee
parce qu'il voulait lui piquer fatto le
bongo il est prêt à en découdre jaloux
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
m le cerveau
permanent de cette photo je
[Rires]
sais tout et non croyants bon visage
c'est très drôle et pas mieux comme ça
très bien non mais vraiment c'est vrai
c'est vrai qu'elle a raison le poème
carradine décolleté débat très mais
vraiment doyer la bouche de décolleté
oui dès lundi
femmes sont souvent des très beaux
garçons mais c'est vrai il est très à
ses fins et l'usap et shrek mais toi tu
eu plus de sa
batterie passe une très bonne émission
ouais bon vous savez pour savoir c'est
ça qu'on a pu pour deux heures ça va
aller très vite il reste une heure et
quart des missions tout va bien un bébé
très heureux vous savez pas va
très bien la pente qu'il fasse
beau temps de le voir il est très beau
ça débute demain que l'on peut les y
attend ça chez vous êtes très bon prof
d'être très bronzé comme ça je ne sais
pas je fais beaucoup de sport je cours
depuis
quand on fait du sport
roi fainéant et il a bronzé bon café
quand on court de relier des
voitures des pour venir la soirée de ses
chats le buzz vous êtes devenus très
très très mytho ouais c'est que la
vérité profonde est aussi bronzée ce que
je peux en mamma qui j'en sais rien je
devais faire à lui et je n'ai pas fait
une semaine
tu aimes temps immobile bcg terme en
polyphénols du vélo a tous regardé
gilles comme il a bonne mine ah oui
c'est vrai je m'entretiens au fait vous
allez ou à noël mais pour les vacances
les 10 jours avec toi déjà pourquoi vous
bougez pas du tout crois que souley n'a
pas peur on pas d'après me bouger pas du
tout il ya deux semaines je voulais pas
partir et partir quoi au soleil à partir
un jour son retour
est-ce que vous avez aimé ce petit on
l'a vu oui oui
est ce qu'on a vu cyril dans le monde
l'a vu j'adore ce lancement c'est france
3 à 1972 et sa place à ce que vous en
voulez encore
[Applaudissements]
c'est parti
à fait partie selon la butte
[Musique]
nicolas pernikoff est bien la vie on
touche à tout achat tous en train de
nous faire son meilleur des hanches et
regarder
vous rendez compte et si vous vous
demandez où isabelle à la quitte rtl
pour rejoindre magali berda après
isabelle morini-bosc voit-il isabelle
kylie jenner
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle est pas mal du tout en effet
guillaume genton la peau qui à phuket et
je peux vous dire qu'il n'a pas bu que
de l'eau celui-ci
[Musique]
enfin philippe boucher elle a ainsi mené
dans nos oreilles on vous a vu faire un
petit tour à bâle et où d'après votre
petit pour n'être pas de la semaine
dernière
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
drôle si le décolleté ça vous va bien
et on embrasse bien voilà je retrouve
vous étés c'était franchement ça il
faudra le refaire
c'est un génie on embrasse cacoub est un
larbin sur mon cas comme qu'on embrasse
à dire salut motion est saluée
[Applaudissements]
m